[Música]
el huevo o la gallina cuál fue primero
la verdad es que no estamos muy seguros de que
el comportamiento de la tecnología cambie cuál
fue primero
¿nos imaginamos alguna vez que
pasaríamos
horas y horas todos los días
revisando nuestros teléfonos para averiguar cuál es nuestro
están haciendo amigos de todo el
mundo
¿alguna vez imaginamos que nos volveríamos
tan adictos a estos dispositivos móviles que
los llevaríamos incluso al baño?
Entonces, ¿cuál fue primero?
es el deseo inherente de conectarse
con otros humanos
y que la tecnología habilitó y
aprovechó ese deseo inherente,
así que pensamos en el espacio educativo,
¿por qué sería diferente?
¿Cuál es la intención de diseño de las
tecnologías que estamos usando para
aprender?  un pequeño paseo hacia atrás
en la historia
esta es una foto del salón de clases en
la década de 1900
hay un maestro y hay un
papel completo de estudiantes ahora estas filas de
estudiantes están juntos  esperando
información de su maestro que tiene
todo el conocimiento
y este conocimiento luego se imparte a
los estudiantes cuyo trabajo es sentarse
pasivamente recibir esa información y
tomar tantas notas como sea posible y
retener tanto como puedan
ahora avancemos rápido hacia  2020
o 2021. Esta es una imagen del
salón de clases de hoy en día,
observe cualquier cosa,
sí, es bastante similar, excepto que
puede tener una pantalla de video y una cámara
y algo de tecnología, tal vez algunas
pizarras electrónicas, pero sigue siendo
el concepto de un maestro o un experto en
el  frente al aula y los estudiantes
sentados
pasivamente recibiendo esa información para
retenerla
y ahora tenemos esta cosa llamada google
y ahora todos llevamos
enciclopedias en el bolsillo, por lo que el conocimiento
está al alcance de la mano, por lo que ya no se
trata solo de conocimiento y no  Realmente no
solo necesitamos que el maestro nos brinde toda la
información que necesitamos,
lo que realmente necesitamos son experiencias para
desarrollar y evolucionar nuevas formas.  de
desarrollar habilidades
ahora aquí hay una imagen de
un salón de clases divertido y algunos de ustedes
dicen que tenemos salones de clase modernos
que se ven así que son divertidos que
son coloridos que son muy interesantes
experienciales y estoy totalmente de acuerdo con
usted y la ciencia y la investigación han demostrado
que este tipo de experiencias participativas sociales
son más efectivas, tienen tasas de
retención más altas y también son más
agradables para todos los involucrados,
entonces, ¿qué pasaría si la
tecnología pudiera usarse con esta
intención de diseño en mente?
¿Qué pasaría si la tecnología pudiera usarse para llegar
a cuatro niveles
de resultados basados en  el modelo
de kirkpatrick de aprender y evolucionar simplemente a partir del
conocimiento
saber cosas hacer pruebas y hacer
evaluaciones desarrollarse a partir de eso para
cambiar el comportamiento y, en última instancia,
desarrollar habilidades
el foro económico mundial habla sobre
habilidades futuras y el futuro del trabajo
no puedo recordarlas todas, así que  Me gustaría
categorizarlos en las cuatro c:
creatividad,
colaboración, comunicación y
pensamiento crítico.  Sin embargo,
toda la verdad sobre estas habilidades
es que no se
pueden obtener fácilmente simplemente mirando videos
o leyendo un libro de texto.
Son habilidades que requieren práctica
y aplicación.
para
facilitar la participación y el compromiso
qué pasaría si la tecnología se
diseñara intencionalmente para ser gamificada para ser divertida
y participar y comprometerse con su grupo
qué pasaría si la tecnología pudiera diseñarse de
tal manera que fuera participativa
qué pasaría si la tecnología pudiera diseñarse  de
tal manera que comportará su
cambio a través de los empujones de aprendizaje y a
través de recordatorios para mejorar la
retención de ese contenido
y qué pasaría si pudiera diseñarse de
tal manera que fomentara el aprendizaje social
si piensa en esta
intención de diseño si esta tecnología existe
lo cual hace
lo que se necesitaría para que cambiemos nuestra
propia forma de pensar porque todos tenemos una
idea preconcebida  una noción mejorada de lo que el
aprendizaje digital y el e-learning y todas
estas plataformas pueden y no pueden hacer,
así que cuando tienes algo nuevo e
innovador y una nueva forma de pensar
acerca de la digitalización de estas
experiencias compartidas, se requiere un cambio de
mentalidad
ahora el primero y todos estos  Los
cambios de mentalidad
requieren decisiones
y pioneros y adoptantes tempranos que estén
dispuestos a probar y probar algo nuevo,
pero también requiere
desaprender. Requiere desaprender nuestras
nociones preconcebidas de lo que era
y quizás es el aprendizaje digital
y luego permitirnos avanzar e
imaginar para imaginar lo que es.  podría ser
y todas estas cosas requieren
cambios de mentalidad y cambios
y lo hermoso es qué pasaría si la
tecnología pudiera usarse como un catalizador
para ese cambio de mentalidad
al repensar y reimaginar cómo seleccionamos
e interactuamos con ese contenido,
así que volviendo a toda esta experiencia
aprendizaje participativo, entonces, ¿cómo se hizo eso
realmente?
Imagínese si luego tomamos el contenido
que sucede en el colorido cla  ssroom,
que es que obtienes una pieza de contenido
y eso es un catalizador para que se produzca el aprendizaje,
luego hay una oferta que es la
parte no, luego hay una oportunidad para pensar,
por lo que esto desarrolla
habilidades de pensamiento crítico y te invita a participar en
esa experiencia.
y luego aplicar
porque para los adultos el aprendizaje tiene que ver con
la aplicación de ese contenido y ese
conocimiento en algo que sea
relevante
y si no practicamos y aplicamos lo
que hemos aprendido, nuestra probabilidad de
recordar eso es muy, muy baja
y finalmente compartir  y al compartir
esas experiencias como adultos,
aprendemos unos de otros.
Yo aprendo de sus experiencias y, con
suerte, ustedes también aprenderán de las mías,
y debido a que venimos con contexto y
experiencias compartidas, este
intercambio es una parte fundamental de una
experiencia de aprendizaje para adultos
y, por lo tanto, si  podríamos tomar la ciencia del
aprendizaje o la andragogía, la ciencia de cómo
aprenden los adultos,
combinar eso con el diseño del comportamiento, empujar
y cambiar el comportamiento
con  principios de gamificación,
podríamos diseñar intencionalmente
tecnología
que impulse una experiencia de aprendizaje compartida
que sea a la vez divertida,
atractiva y efectiva,
entonces, ¿qué se necesita?
Se necesita un cambio de mentalidad.
Se necesita que una persona tome la decisión de
probar algo nuevo
y esté dispuesto.  cometer errores en
ese proceso
cuando hablamos de la forma de aprender
y ahora curar de una manera diferente y
vamos a diseñar utilizando la tecnología
de esta nueva manera
, tenemos que detener algunas de las viejas
formas para adoptar lo nuevo
y  Entonces, si la tecnología lo alentó a
reimaginar su contenido de una
manera experiencial social, eso podría ser un
poderoso catalizador para impulsar realmente el
cambio a una escala más amplia,
ahora es el momento,
creo que nos lo debemos a nosotros mismos y a
las generaciones futuras
para reimaginar
cómo aprendemos
y  cómo enseñamos
porque tenemos que ir más allá de la
pedagogía basada en el conocimiento y los métodos de enseñanza basados en el conocimiento
porque el mundo requiere habilidades
pensamiento crítico toma de decisiones s  El
pensamiento del sistema y todas estas cosas
que no se reemplazan fácilmente con IA
son las mismas cosas que necesitamos
desarrollar
, así que imagina si la tecnología pudiera
diseñarse intencionalmente para catalizar y
acelerar este tipo de aprendizaje.
La buena noticia es que es
posible. Te invito a  únete a mí en el viaje
[Música]
tú